i want to say first of all how much i
sympathize with people who've
been worried about their journeys
worried about whether they'll be able to
uh use their cars in in the normal way
to see their loved ones or or
whatever it is and i know how
frustrating and infuriating it must have
been to worry about a shortage of petrol
of fuel
um we now are starting to see the
situation improve we're hearing from
industry that uh supplies are coming
back onto the four courts in uh in the
normal way
and
i would just
really urge everybody to
just go about their business in the in
the normal way and and fill up in the
normal way when you when you really need
it and uh and you know things are uh
will start to improve what we want to do
is make sure that we have
all the
preparations necessary to get through
till christmas and beyond not just in
the
uh supplying the the petrol stations but
all parts of our supply chain you're
seeing the the global economy really
sucking in a huge amount of demand at
the moment uh for for gas for lorry
drivers or shortages around the world
it's affecting uh countries across
across the world but we've got to make
sure we have everything in place
as the as the recovery continues and
that's what we're doing
you did say that this would be short
term
now you're saying that there could be
problems to christmas and beyond
well i don't want you to
put words into my mouth here we want to
make sure that as the uh
economy continues to recover as we
continue to see things
the global recoveries suck in demand of
of all kinds whether for gas or for for
lorry drivers uh that the uk is prepared
then we have a plan that's what we've
we've done what we've done on uh
relaxing the competition rules and
making sure that we
have more drivers available should we
need them uh that's only prudent but i
would just stress that on the on on the
four courts the the situation is is
stabilizing and people should be uh
confident and and just go about their
their business in their normal way one
of the most difficult aspects of this is
seeing reports of doctors of nurses
medics struggling to get fuel to go
about their business isn't it right that
they get a chance to jump the queue
i understand why people say that but
with the situation now stabilizing with
things getting better on the full course
i think that the best thing is if is if
everybody uh just
we we stabilize it in the normal way
are all the solutions to the truck
driver shortages in place now are you
have you got any other contingencies in
mind are you preparing for
the potential that it gets worse
i think what happened with the with the
fuel uh issue with with the petrol uh
pump business was that unfortunately
there was a there was a slightly
misleading account of of something which
got which got leaked and caused a big uh
totally understandable surge in in
public demand uh we think we can
you know the the actual number of lorry
drivers that were short in that
particular sector isn't isn't very big
but generally there is a there is a
shortage in in that profession around
the world and what we want to see
is a an emphasis on high wage a high
skill a high productivity approach to
our economy what i don't think people in
this country want to do is fix
all our problems
with uncontrolled immigration again we
we tried that for a long time
20 years or so perhaps longer and
in the end people could see that it was
leading to a low-wage low-skill approach
without enough investment in people or
in uh in in equipment in capital and
that's not the way we want the uk uh to
develop and grow
shortages push up prices inflation is up
energy costs up people are going to be
hard-pressed this autumn for those
worried about the cost of living do you
understand the pressures on families is
there any signal that you can give that
you're looking at that issue ahead of
the autumn statement
which is why we're so
we're emphasizing so much what we've
done on the on the living wage uh making
sure that uh we've increased that by a
record amount but while we're also uh
i'm i'm pleased that after after
10 years or more 12 13 years of of wages
flatlining particularly for uh for low
paid people you're now starting to see
an increase in wages and i think people
in this country do deserve to be paid
decently it's one of the things we
fought for and campaigned for and you're
now starting to see an increase in
people's wages uh of uh maybe four uh
percent above where we were before the
pandemic now i think that is a is a good
thing and what i don't want our country
to do is to go back to which is what i
think some people would rather see some
people would rather see us
suppress those wages uh with uh a huge
amount of uh of uh of low wage low
school immigration but they're more
government help for hard-pressed
families in the coming weeks and months
we'll do whatever we can as as we said
throughout the pandemic to help people
but the best way we can help people is
to get them into uh high-wage employment
and that you're starting to see a real
signs of progress our plan for jobs is
working you're seeing growth in
employment a huge falls in uh
unemployment and as i say you're seeing
wages uh considerably above where they
were uh before the uh before the before
the pandemic um prime minister you have
to pitch yourself we've got um a gas
price hike trucker shortages food
shortages cues the army on standby you'd
call this a crisis if anybody else was
in downing street wouldn't he
what we've got is a global economy that
is recovering from what has been a
a once in a century pandemic and that
has caused some particular shortages
i've mentioned a couple hdv drivers and
and
gas and those shortages are a function
of huge global demand but we're meeting
them and what we have is uh all sorts of
plans in place to make sure that as we
go forward uh into the into the new year
uh that we have the everything necessary
to protect our supply chains and keep
things moving but uh as i said what
we're seeing now what we're hearing now
from
industry is that the situation on the
four courts
in our petrol stations is stabilizing